go to any of the most beautiful places
in the world and you see people taking
pictures of themselves we think of this
as a new thing
selfie only made it into the Oxford
English Dictionary in 2013 when it
quickly became word of the year but
selfies are about us all as photography
the first was taken in 1839 by an
American named Robert Cornelius so why
have we used photography this miraculous
invention to take pictures of something
we can see in our bathroom mirror every
morning something odd is clearly going
on and who better to explain human
oddities than Sigmund Freud Freud
invented psychoanalysis and popularized
many ideas like the ego the unconscious
and talking to a therapist one of those
ideas is narcissism or excessive
self-love in a Greek myth a young man
called narcissus sees his reflection in
a pool and spent so long staring at his
own beauty but he loses touch with the
rest of the world and eventually drowns
trying to embrace his own image in the
water Freud thought that a bit of
self-love was a natural part of being
human but Freud also thought that
self-love can turn into a psychological
disorder when someone loves himself to
the exclusion of everyone and everything
else and that's what we usually mean by
narcissism psychologists have developed
tests for measuring personality traits
like narcissism here are some results
narcissists do tend to be more active on
social media and posting selfies is
strongly related to narcissism but only
if you are a man women tend to be less
narcissistic than men even though women
post more selfies perhaps more
worryingly narcissism is rising the
psychologist Jean Twenge has shown that
over the past few decades it's risen at
roughly the same rate as obesity Freud
derived most of his insights from
everyday life observations so he would
have been very interested in all this
data he would have concluded that
narcissism is only part of what's going
on in the rise of selfie culture some
people are posting selfies not because
they are in love with
selves but because they want other
people to be in love with them Freud
would have seen that need for approval
as neurotic or hysterical Freud began
his career in the late 1800s a much more
sexually repressed time men and women
were kept strictly separated and they
were thought to be ashamed of feeling
sexy many of frauds female patients and
Viennese high society suffered from
hysterical paralysis an inability to
walk that had no physical course Freud
believed that these women were without
knowing it stopping themselves from
walking because they wanted attention so
if we need attention so badly that will
paralyze ourselves for it why not post a
few selfies isn't that better
well Freud would find something
unhealthy about selfies not just because
of what they say about the people taking
them but also because of what they do to
the people seeing them selfies show
people's best moments carefully curated
and heavily staged managed so we're
increasingly surrounded by images of
other people's apparently perfect lives
and bodies recent studies show that this
makes us feel more envy inadequacy
isolation and insecurity making us in
Freud's terms more neurotic Freud said
the aim of psychoanalysis is to replace
the erotic misery with ordinary human
and happiness so next time you reach for
the camera
remember narcissus and focus on your
friends instead you may not get as many
likes but you'll get a thumbs up from
Freud
you